well well first of all i'm gonna be a
fan also and i'm gonna congratulate you
chris
on getting to the finals i know how
difficult this journey
is for us as small men right trying to
trying to get here and there
there have been a lot of nights where
i'm sure you
you wondered if you would ever get there
just like i wondered if i would ever get
there
uh but it seems like right now you have
found the right
place for you in terms of
james jones being the general manager
monty williams being the coach
and then you being the coach out on the
floor and it it just feels like this is
the
the perfect the perfect storm and a
perfect situation for you
arriving in the finals and and then
having
the support and also the knowledge base
in the front office that you can
orchestrate and
dictate out on the floor how does that
feel for you
as a player right now well it's a lot of
trust and i'm a fan of the game too so
obviously zeke i watched you
all day every day watched kenny hell i
played against shaq
got sent to the floor a couple of times
because shaq was a hack man
used to just foul you just to just to
let you know he was there
just to let you know he was there but
but with our team man i think what i
love is the trust
the trust factor y'all know y'all didn't
play it in the league when practice over
if you see a guy
lead a gym and then game coming you kick
it to him you like hey man
you don't work on that you don't work on
that but with our team we got such a
work team
a work team so that when we got a thing
i keep saying it tonight we call it good
to great
you know i mean if i got a good shot i
trust the next guy that i can pass it up
if he got a great shot and
when you do that all season long and the
coaches drill it day in and day out
you trust the system and and i just want
to say one more thing
i'm honored to be compared and all names
are mentioned
in the same graph you honored i think no
no really i'm honored i'm honored